I don't think we need an emergency
option I think we can take the plunge
and go for it and play Knight takes E5
and the better calculator is going to
win this game there's this is going to
get really exciting maybe it's losing
for white I don't know
but at this point I think just out of
principle we need to take the plunge
I think we might need to give up a piece
and hope for the best
wow
I got thoroughly out calculated here I
think what we need to do is cut our
losses
[Music]
okay nikito 3001 I do want to play E4 in
this game even though we've been kind of
toggling between the jababa London uh
and 1e4 but let's Resort back to our
main repertoire especially because we're
facing the Karo Khan yet again and
anybody who's watched the speedrun for
any length of time should know what move
I wholeheartedly recommend against the
karokan this I think is the best weapon
for Club players for beginner turn
intermediate players by far and that is
of course the fantasy it is the
Kryptonite of the majority of Karo Khan
players for two main reasons it's less
well-known than Knight C3 E5 and E takes
D5 the kind of Mainline Trifecta so it's
less studied and two it leads to
extremely tactical positions so black
can't get away with just making Karo
Khan moves and improvising okay so Pawn
takes E4 and E5 is what everybody seems
to be playing against us this is the
main line and if you've watched the
previous speedrun game there was one a
couple of games ago where we sacrificed
Our Queen it was an amazing game and
this exact line was featured in that
game so you should know that the move is
not Pawn takes E5 not because of the
queen trade although that's also fine
for black but of course because of Queen
H4 check and then the queen picks up the
pawn on e4 instead we prioritize
development we bring our Knight out to
F3 black plays Bishop G4 which is the
best move the old line is e takes D4
which almost loses I've analyzed that
pretty extensively throughout the
speedrun games and on Bishop G4
I've kind of advocated for two different
lines the line that I myself play with
white is this move C3 solidifying the
center and then bringing the light
squirt Bishop out to E2 but the move
that I recommend to players in the sort
of 1800 to 2000 Range is the more
ambitious more popular move which is
Bishop to C4 which really forces black
to demonstrate very extensive
theoretical knowledge in order to attain
a good position and leads to countless
tactical traps now I don't know Bishop
C4 as well as C3 but again for the
purposes of the speeder and I'm willing
to put myself on the line and improvise
if necessary let's bring the bishop out
to C4 now we've already had a game where
Bishop takes F7 check was overlooked by
our opponent of course this guy clearly
knows what he's doing Knight to D7 is
correct and I've already explained
previously why Bishop takes F7 doesn't
work here so you know if you're watching
on YouTube and you don't uh remember the
previous Fantasy games it might be worth
pausing and you know doing a quick run
through of the previous Fantasy games to
acquaint yourself with the basic Theory
because I'm not going to repeat you know
the same basic observations we're just
gonna go straight into the correct line
of play which is of course to Castle
kingside and this is one of the biggest
appeals of the fantasy you get this
semi-openf file on which you can
engineer A Massive Attack if black is
not careful Bishop takes F7 of course is
once again reinforced as a threat black
plays Knight Knight F6 and now it's time
for us to solidify our Center because
once black gets a couple of pieces out
Pawn takes Pawn is now a rather uh nasty
Prospect right our Center is part of the
reason part of the appeal of the fantasy
so we need to take the sting out of the
move he takes D4 note that pawn takes E5
is not effective not because of Knight
takes C5 that loses a piece but rather
because black and first take the Knight
on F3 then recapture on E5 and again our
Center sort of evaporates so once again
we need to play this move C3 and you
might say well what about the Knight on
B1 well don't worry about the Knight
because the Knight can be brought out
via D2 later on in the game this Knight
is not essential to our general
development into the health of our
position as things stand but before
bringing the night out to D2 of course
it's always a good idea to bring your
Bishop out first this is pretty standard
fare you don't want to block the
development of one piece by bringing out
another piece so it's important for us
to find suitable employment for our
Bishop and there's really only one
reasonable Square all of this has
happened in previous speedrun games
we've followed this main line to to the
T being gone more than one occasion and
around this point I think is where most
players in the 2000 chess.com range are
out of theory but I've been pretty
surprised by the knowledge displayed by
a couple of our opponents H6
okay and of course we drop our Bishop
back to H4 we're trying to provoke the
move G5 which our opponent plays so now
of course we drop our Bishop back to G 3
and again you should remember that
Knight takes E4 is never a major problem
because Bishop takes F7 check always
exists in response this might be what we
faced last time but I don't really
remember Bishop G3 Queen E7 okay so
clearly our opponent knows absolutely
everything here so we're on our own
let's think about this for a second I
think we might have faced this exact
sequence before
I'm definitely out of theory I will
admit we're on our own here
and it might very well be that we face
this exact sequence and I just don't
remember but
please forgive me it is pretty late and
my memory for openings is a lot worse
than people realize so clearly first of
all clearly this guy did extremely
serious war against the fantasy
now as I see it the point of Queen E7 is
pretty clear black is solidifying his
control over the E5 pawn and preparing
to Castle Queen side which is going to
lead to an opposite side castling
situation where both sides are going to
use their pawns to attack the opposing
side's King so black has this clear plan
of h5h4 we on the other hand have our
own methods of approaching Black's King
we can play A4 A5 but we can also deploy
Our Queen to B3 or even to A4 and try to
harass and massage some of these weak
pawns on the queen side but all of that
is beyond the scope of this position
first of all we need to complete our
development we need to play Knight bd2
and we need to wait for black to put his
cards on the table okay Castle's Queen
side
now
My worry is that if we start storming
with our pawns if we play a move like A4
we apply what I call the best case
scenario test where we say okay let's
say our opponent allows us to do exactly
what we want to do how good is that
going to be well even if we get our Pawn
all the way up to A6 that's not as big
of a deal as it may appear because black
can just push the beep on forward like
B5 we've wasted three Tempe and all
we've done is induce you know an
unexploitable weakness on C6 which
cannot be approached so I think A4 is
ineffective I think we need to try to
attack with our pieces well what pieces
can we recruit for the purpose of
pressuring Black's Queen side there's
also a weakness on F7 by the way which
you shouldn't forget about well to me
the queen is the only piece that can be
immediately recruited we can play them
move Queen to A4 which is actually quite
interesting
we can try to induce black into playing
King B8 and then drop our Queen back to
B3
in the appeal of forcing King B8 is that
the queen on B3 would then be x-raying
the b-pawn which could add some spice to
the position
you should also note that after Queen A4
B5 which May Scare some people off is
not a problem because we have Queen to
A6 check at a minimum in order to get
the queen out of the tempo and then we
can move our Bishop
so I like Queen B3 I like Queen A4 I
think Queen A4 is less likely to be
considered by our opponent so let's try
to throw him off of uh his theory with
Queen to A4
now if he knows this move then I take my
hat off absolutely
but very often what you see when players
are incredibly well prepared
and armed to the teeth that can actually
backfire because sometimes when the
analysis cuts off abruptly and you're
suddenly posed with a decision of your
own it you know that situation is very
dangerous the move right after you exit
your prep is extremely notorious for
being you know the site of a lot of
immediate mistakes
and probably you can kind of relate to
that
you know and remember a game where you
were super well prepared and super
excited then your opponent plays a movie
didn't consider you're mad at yourself
for not considering it because it's
actually pretty reasonable and you know
as a result you panic and make a mistake
so Knight to B6 here is not an issue
that is why we put the Knight on D2 the
bishop is buttressed by the Knight so
Knight B6 we play Queen takes A7 simply
that's a blunder
Knight takes Bishop Knight takes Knight
and if our Knight gets to C4 that there
will be hell to pay for black because
the B6 Square could be used as an
attacking post for the night
so I'm anticipating King to B8 but it's
a good sign that our opponent is
actually thinking
and the other way to defend of course is
A6
but A6 would be absolute music to my
ears in fact if you watched my Blitz
Games or my speed run for any length of
time you should know what move I'm
itching to make in the event of A6
that of course is Bishop to A6 which is
not even really a sacrifice if you think
about it because how many pawns are you
getting for the piece well you're
getting one then you're gonna grab the
pawn on C6 with check because remember
the B Pawn is going to have to take the
bishop and if you want you could even
take a third Pawn on A6 which probably
we don't want
probably what we would do there is bring
the Knight into the attack with Knight
to C4
A6 would be amazing for us see what our
opponent comes up with he's now invested
two minutes into this position I suppose
Bishop D6 can drop back to B8
but already there are some bowdoin's
mate type ideas okay King B8 let's drop
the queen back to B3 that's kind of what
we decided so let's not uh tarry any
further and just drop the queen back
because already here already here B5 had
become a slightly bigger problem
although I guess we still would have had
Queen B3 but the queen on A4 has
overstayed its welcome the only point of
this move is to get the skin to drag it
onto B8 now there might be some
cognitive dissonance because you might
have heard me share this advice that
when you Castle queenside often tucking
the king away on B8 is a good thing
right it's safer on B8 or B1 than it is
on C8 or C1 but this is an exception to
the rule because we've got this queen
and because we've got this x-ray we're
basically trying to gain Tempe and here
A4 A5 A6 is a little bit more effective
because the king is kind of in the
crosshairs of the queen
hopefully that kind of makes sense now
I'm not really doing too much
calculation I'm just trying to cause
some practical problems for our opponent
to pose some dilemmas
and that's what leads to mistakes
now also Bishop A6 of course is a very
serious idea here
now Bishop A6 May strike you as just a
an empty one move threat but it's not
because if we can force black to play B6
well that's a very serious weakening of
the queen side and this is technically
the queen side even though Black's King
is located there
but geographically it's still still the
queen side
so once the bishop vacates the C4 Square
the Knight can also jump into C4 and
once that happens the pressure on the E5
Pawn grows very powerful so let's not
short-sightedly you know section the
board off and assume that we're just
operating on these three files we're
also operating in the center now we've
got three attackers on the E5 Pawn
and we're attacking the F7 Pawn which
absolutely we might want to take in the
absence of a better move
I think we've succeeded in imposing
practical problems to Black
yeah and that's the thing if we are able
to play Bishop A6 and black covers with
the Knight then D takes E5 as things
stand currently with simply win the game
because it would Fork the bishop in the
Knight I suppose black would have Bishop
C5 check
but even after King H1 that Bishop will
x-ray the king another good reason to
drag Black's King to B8 the fact that
the bishop on G3 x-rays the black king
doesn't seem important now but if the
bishop ever leaves D6 it absolutely will
become important quick shout out to
people watching on YouTube
thank you for all of the kind words and
all of the subscriptions
Knight to H5 yeah that's
what I was a little bit worried about
but then I actually think upon closer
inspection this might be a mistake
uh to get people's hopes up so what is
the purpose of Knight H5 well the
purpose is very clear
black is trying to eliminate the dark
squared Bishop in order to relieve the
pressure on the E5 Pawn so obviously
Bishop takes F7 is possible but what
strikes it move strikes me is very
awkward and not a good use of our time
because after the trade on G3 black and
start running that H Pawn down the board
and those doubled g-pawns will serve as
what's called hooks right and a hook in
attacking terminologies when you advance
upon and you kind of use an opponent's
Pawn as gunpowder to to blast open the
king side and that Bishop on F7 is going
to have to be evacuated if we are to
operate on the queen side so we're gonna
have to waste another Tempo on Bishop C4
and the openf file might actually favor
Black if we ever need to make a Mad Dash
for the center of the board I don't like
Bishop F7 I think we should stick to our
guns here
what does it mean to stick to our guns
well we need to generate threats against
Black's King well we already know the
best way to do that I think the best way
to do that
is well let me think about this I think
it probably is Bishop A6 although upon
closer examination Bishop A6 Knight B6
oh and there we've got Knight takes C5 I
think this might be working out for us
I think we should go Bishop A6
this creates a host of problems for
black if we can get black to play B6
we've already discussed that that favors
white and we can follow up with Knight
to C4
creating serious problems for Black's
King now from C4 the Knight could
potentially even jump into A5 again
reaping the benefits of this x-ray is
one of the themes of our attack
if black plays Knight to B6 then we need
to be very careful
to be careful we need to start
calculating concretely
now what do we do
in response to Knight to B6 well
after Knight B6 the bishop hangs so we
need to play with Tempo so Knight takes
E5 comes to mind how do I see this move
well once the Knight moves away from D7
you should realize that black
relinquishes
their control over E5 so Knight to B6
Knight takes E5
at that point black can't take the
bishop because the Knight dives into C6
with a fork on the king and the queen so
after Knight B6 Knight takes E5 if black
plays Bishop takes E5 we recapture with
the bishop and we're chilling because
that's also a check and it hits the rook
in the corner that's out of the question
the more concerning line is Knight takes
E5 Knight takes G3 Knight takes G3 first
because there if we simply recapture on
G3 which actually might be the best move
I don't know well we'll cross that
bridge if we get there
black will then be able to play Bishop
take C5
and perhaps
it's hard for you to visualize this line
but the bottom line is when all of the
Smoke Clears that Bishop on A6 is going
to be hanging
right if the Knight on E5 is eliminated
and the bishop on G3 is eliminated all
that we would have left is this Knight
on D2
and we wouldn't have that Knight on E5
that that defends indirectly against B
takes A6 if that makes sense again don't
worry about visualizing this I'll show
all of this after after the game as well
and our opponent of course goes for
Knight B6 really no other choice for
black I think
let's think about this for a moment okay
I think we should take the plunge now
there is an alternative to playing
Knight takes Pawn
and the alternative to playing Knight
takes Pawn is of course to take the pawn
with the bishop
if we take the pawn of the bishop my
issue is that black and play ba
we take the Rook black takes on h8 and
black has two minor pieces for a rook
which normally in these sharp middle
games favor the side of the minor pieces
because minor Pieces Just are are more
effective attackers when there are
closed files so that would be an
emergency option I don't think we need
an emergency option I think we can take
the plunge and go for it and play Knight
takes E5 and the better calculator is
going to win this game
there's this is going to get really
exciting maybe it's losing for white I
don't know
but at this point I think just out of
principle we need to take the plunge
we need to take the plunge here there
are some okay Bishop E6 well that's kind
of a cop-out move and there was one
crazy tactic that worried me
this was not it although now I see that
I blundered or at least I underestimated
this I think
I guess I seriously underestimated this
move wait let's think about this
let me focus in silence for a moment
because there's a lot to think about
here and we're in danger
somehow I I saw this move but I didn't
realize it was actually a big problem
but now I see that it is man last few
Speed Run games have been difficult
I think we might need to give up a piece
and hope for the best wow
I got thoroughly out calculated here I
think what we need to do is cut our
losses and the reason we need to cut our
losses is because I forgot that I
thought we could just move our Queen
back to be completely honest I thought
we could move our Queen back and black
still can't take the bishop but again I
forgot the black and first take this
other Bishop then take the Knight and
then take the bishop on A6 in that order
now Bishop C4 comes to mind
but the problem there is that black
still takes the bishop then black takes
the Knight on E5 and suddenly the Knight
on D2 hangs as The Rook is x-raying the
Knight
The Rook is x-raying the Knight so what
we need to do is give up a piece but
extract the maximum material out of it
we're gonna lose one of these pieces so
how do we gracefully give a piece up in
order to extract the maximum concessions
from black well the only way to do this
in the interest of time is actually
Knight takes C6 check without this
resource I think we're dead on the spot
with this resource I think we have
pretty decent practical chances I don't
know what our opponent is thinking about
here because BC is absolutely forced but
maybe this has come as a surprise to him
okay so after BC we play Bishop takes D6
check and I will admit I messed up we're
probably objectively not lost I would
not say that white is lost here white is
worse but practically we have very
serious compensation in what form well
first of all we have two pawns so it's
not like we're down a full piece for
nothing and of course we have long-term
chances against Black's King which you
know will basically need to play
perfectly the rest of this game to avoid
losing it
I got out calcul out prepared and then
out calculated completely so Kudos but
let's see how our opponent plays the
technical phase of the game all right
so we need to move our Queen back we can
move it back to D1 to hit the Knight but
the Knight wants to go to F4 anyway I
think it's a better use of our Queen to
stick it on C2 because it's just a
little bit more out of the way and it
leaves the Rooks more coordinated so I
like this more than Queen D1 even though
that move occurs with Tempo and one hack
for trying to climb out of these
difficult positions is you want to give
your opponent as much rope as possible
you want to give black as many decisions
as possible
for two reasons of course the time
situation right seven and a half minutes
isn't a lot of time and second of all
the more decisions your opponent has to
make the more nervous they're gonna get
so these more open-ended moves can
actually be a very powerful defensive
tool rather than just automatically
going for the forcing lines now we need
to press on the guess we have to find a
way to expose Black's king and the only
vehicle toward exposing Black's King is
to get rid of the B6 Knight and the only
way to do that is to run this a pawn
down the board so we'll start with the
move A4 and we'll hope for the best
yeah we'll start with a 4a5
unfortunately we can never play Queen B3
Queen B7 because of this darn Bishop on
E6 but tactically we could potentially
shut the bishop out with a well-timed D5
so keep that in mind keep in mind that
D5 and I would play King A8 here with
black but you know all of this is not
trivial at all for a 2000 player so
we're just gonna keep peppering black
with decisions and dilemmas and
hopefully eventually he cracks
although it might take a long while
yeah it's actually not trivial at all
here because in a weird kind of way
our King is pretty safe for the time
being it's gonna take a while for black
to coordinate his pieces enough to get
to our King you should also note that if
black ever plays G4 that would be a
major blunder because of E5 slicing off
the connection between the queen and the
Knight
so G4 G3 is hard to engineer as well and
without that Arc King is perfectly safe
for the time being
yeah whitesnite has you know C5 as an
outpost
of course we would have to go through
Bishop takes B3 and weigh the pros and
cons of that trade
and on that topic when you're down a
piece let's say for two puns you
absolutely should not rule out trades
just in general trades can actually be
good when done strategically of course a
queen trade would be a pretty pretty
disastrous here for white but
you know a minor piece trade could be
okay okay
I think that we need to spice things up
a little bit more on the queen side now
if we rush with A5 if we rush with A5
the problem is that after black drops
the Knight back to D7 black will have
this very nasty threat of C5 which can
be a little bit hard to visualize but
what that does is opens up an attack on
the bishop on A6
and forces it away whereas we want to
keep that Bishop on A6 as long as
possible so I think what we should try
to do is delay the move A5 until we're
ready to play it and instead I think we
should continue kind of activating and
spicing things up on the queen Side by
grabbing more space with B4 this also
prevents black from playing C5 and again
I'm trying to give black as much rope as
possible a lot of people here would be
tempted to play G4 that's an
understandable move you know let's start
attacking
I think the better move would be H5 but
again an advanced decision that has to
be made by black and he's really
starting to run low on time
and I know that you know using our
opponent's clock isn't really in this in
the spirit of the speedrun but at this
level I'm trying to give you a realistic
portrayal of exactly how I'm I would
play how I would treat this and no
matter what time control you play most
people watching this aren't going to be
playing a Time control over 15 plus 10.
so hopefully that advice about milking
your opponent's clock is an entirely
cheap
I wouldn't say this is bad for black but
in a weird way it's very very hard to
play
it's hard for black to find a way to
make progress you just almost don't feel
the extra piece I think if I had to
assess the engine evaluation here I
would guess something like minus one or
minus 1.5 which is a lot black is
clearly better but I wouldn't say it's
more than minus two
you know it's it's practically very
difficult
and our opponent is spending over a
minute a move which is really really
good for us now it's not so easy for a
white to make progress on the queen side
either
obviously after we play A5 and we knock
the Knight away let's say back to D7
well what are we gonna do after that
well of course there's a possibility of
us going B5 but let's put all that aside
because Bishop C it is a big decision
Bishop C it is a big decision
and we have a very interesting tactical
idea here that has to be properly
fleshed out so let me try to calculate
it
oh it's really cool
we have a very cool move here and again
this move if calculated correctly is
sexy if not well then it's a very bad
move because we can simply Play Bishop
takes C8 and then A5 but he but we can
also play A5 right away and after Bishop
takes Bishop a takes B6 Bishop takes F1
Rook takes a seven check and then the
queen joins into the attack via A4
setting up mating patterns along the
lines of Rook A8 and queen A7 I think
that works out I think that we should
start with A5 again
forcing our opponent to calculate to
honor this and calculate Bishop A6 now
the Practical player might just trust
white and say okay I trust you I'm gonna
go Knight D7 quickly but most again you
know that takes a lot of experience it's
also easy to just fall into the rabbit
hole and start calculating and then you
look up and you have one minute
okay so so notice really what I'm trying
to do here posing problems on every
single move and imperceptibly Black's
clock is starting to dwindle
the additional benefit of this move is
that had we immediately taken on C8
black would have had the extra
possibility of Knight takes C8 whereas
now the Knight doesn't have C8 and has
to drop back to D7 then we can play
Bishop takes C8 or we could even play
Knight to C4 with tempo and we're
starting to really accumulate those
pieces on the queen side so notice
what's happening to Black's clock
another minute is being spent not to get
too obsessed with Black's clock but it's
kind of fun to watch a tick down
because you start feeling
that you start feeling the nerves from
your opponent and that's always a good
feeling and I also see a really really
cool tactic which hopefully will have a
chance to implement
okay less than three minutes now for our
opponent and he doesn't budge Knight D7
okay now I think that we should play
Knight to C4 and again we can delay
Bishop takes C8 buy a move because we
know that we're gonna play Knight to C4
anyway right that's a move that should
be completely obvious to you because it
brings the Knight into attacking
position
but there's also a hidden tactic that I
think we might get a chance to implement
if our opponent
reacts incorrectly
so let's tease black with another
dilemma one after the other after the
other every move is another dilemma that
we're forcing black into
and hopefully if he takes another minute
you know then he's gonna be under two
minutes
now here we're forcing black to decide
where he wants to put his Queen
so let's see what our opponent decides
no but I have to give tremendous credit
to our opponent for just tremendous play
so far but we've obviously made huge
strides ever since giving the piece away
and he finds Queen C7 okay I was really
hoping for Queen to E6 no such luck
now we have no choice you don't want to
overdo this so sometimes if your move is
forced then your move is forced we have
no choice we have to play Bishop takes
C8 maybe B5 merited a little bit more
consideration there but I don't think so
all right now we cannot rest on our
Laurels we have to keep the foot on the
gas pedal so to speak we have to keep
making progress and posing black with
newer and newer problems in order to
keep the momentum of the game going
because we are down in peace now we
should remember that that does not mean
tunnel visioning the queen side this is
what I've been saying at the start you
have to look at all sides of the board
and if you look at the king side you
might say well wait a second I'm looking
at this F7 Pawn I'm looking at this
Knight and I'm looking at my rook and
I'm saying why can't I simply play G3
Force the Knight out of f4 and take
another freaking Pawn on F7 and once
that pawn is captured the E4 Pawn
becomes a passer which basically means
that all end games are going to be good
for white as well
so G3 why would this be a
counter-intuitive move for some people
well it weakens the king a little bit
but with the reduced material on the
board and the lack of a light squared
Bishop
we're really not paying the price for
this move that we otherwise would have
and the pawn and F7 is is just juicy AF
also once we take F7 we develop massive
tactical potential along the seventh
rank one thing that you should
absolutely see if you're tactically
sharp is the presence of Knight to B6
check which could be okay obviously King
G2
and now Rook takes F7 we can make these
two moves very quickly
and wait a second there might be a
game-winning tactic here and this is
beautiful
this is beautiful
so how do I see this well there's a
couple of elements here well there's the
pan along the seventh rank
and then there is the X-ray along the a
file and these two things combined
should lead you to the move Knight to B6
check
now it's not hard to calculate this if
Knight takes B6 then we take on C7 and
you might say well what about Rook F2
check there well Rook F2 check you can
always play Queen takes F2 and give the
queen up for a rook and a piece
after Knight B6 check a b a b is a
discovered check that wins the queen on
C7 and the game
and on that note we can simply Drive the
Knight into B6
yeah really really pretty
because this uses multiple tactical
features to make it work if our Rook had
not been on F7 then black would be able
to keep the a file closed with Knight
takes B6
right A B Queen takes B6 big deal
so now we use both of our Rooks in order
to indirectly support the Knight
there's a beautiful follow-up I'm I
don't think this is gonna happen but
black can also play the move Queen takes
B6
and try to basically give the queen up
for a maximum amount of material of
course Queen takes B6 we can play Rook
takes f8 check first
all right very important intermediate
move so that the Rook doesn't hang but I
also see an incredible idea
now I don't know if we should play this
because this is not in the spirit of the
speedrun to play only for beauty
the business move is Rook takes f8 check
and then a takes B6 and we're completely
winning
but there is also a really really pretty
line
that goes a b Rook takes F7 Rook takes
A7 King to B8 and then that position
there's a game-winning tactic that's
really gorgeous
but again I don't want to do this
because our goal is to play objectively
I will show you after the game
but what is the purpose of the speed run
it's the play accurate chess and
accurate chess dictates that you should
simply take on f8 and take on B6 as much
as I would love to do it okay so
obviously here we play Queen F2
and the simplest is just Rook takes A7
check a little intermediate move and we
win absolutely everything you can choose
which Knight to take uh Rook takes D7 of
course black will play Knight takes E4
so I think the simplest is King takes F2
and then swing The Rook over to the
other side of the board and start
chomping off uh all of Black's pawns on
the king side it's all over
so our attack has succeeded what a game
that was fun
and there's a good theoretical component
here because I've struggled in this
fantasy line on several occasions now
maybe Queen A4 Queen B3 is the top move
I because I remembered this idea of
Queen A4 I remembered it
from our earlier Fantasy game I just
didn't remember the exact context
okay so let's analyze thankfully we
didn't get disconnected
so again in earlier Fantasy games I gave
you the sort of overview of other lines
here because we're at a higher level
we're going to focus directly on the
line that our opponent played so Bishop
C4
again C3 is an alternative
uh to remember
so the one thing I will say is that
Knight F6 is a very common mistake here
Bishop takes F7 and Knight takes C5 uh
wins the game because the Knight comes
back and takes division so Knight D7
castles Knight F6
and C3 solidifying the center
yeah Bishop D6 Bishop G5
uh still Mainline
and now H6 is actually not that common
Bishop H4 G5 yeah this is what we faced
I think this is exactly what we faced in
an earlier Fantasy game
and I don't remember exactly how that
game went but I'm I'm seeing this game
sitchever against svane and for some
reason I remember citing that game
earlier so maybe this is some
recommendation in a chessable course or
in some article that's going around
because now two people have played this
exact thing yeah so I remembered
correctly I remember that Queen A4 was
an engine idea here Queen A4 Queen B3
and for some reason you know maybe it
wasn't exactly here but that's what
influenced my decision
so Queen A4
is not a good move though I did confuse
something
it's not a great move although black has
to be ultra precise
so I actually don't think Queen A4 is a
bad idea
according to the engine in this position
white is not better here so clearly this
is some recommendation
I don't know who came up with this oh
it's in the lemie course
it's apparently it's in the Irwin lemie
chessable course on the Karo Khan that
would make perfect sense
so apparently Queen C2 is the top engine
move which is a modest move with the aim
of solidifying the E4 Pawn but if you
have to play that then it's pretty meh
also interesting is the immediate Queen
B3 according to the computer
and now if black plays Bishop takes F3
which is the top engine move
Rook takes F3
is the line e takes D4
C takes D4 looks scary for black but
apparently this works out quite nicely
for black
Rook takes F3
e takes D4 C takes D4 Bishop G3 HG and
black actually gets away with the move
Knight takes E4 as crazy as it seems
because after Rook takes F7 black takes
on D2 and hits the queen
and the liquidation leads to an equal
end game
I mean I if I was judging this visually
I would take white but the engine
actually prefers Black by a tiny margin
after Rook HD it so it's a draw this is
an equal end game it can be played by
both sides
so that's an interesting line now after
Queen B3 if black does not know Bishop
takes F3 which to me is far from
intuitive I to me like Knight H5 would
be the intuitive move but Knight H5
loses
two Knight takes E5
oh my gosh
oh this is beautiful and if black plays
Knight takes G3
okay this is incredible on so many
levels so what is White's best move here
now obviously it's not HG because then
black just takes on E5 the intuitive
move is Rook takes F7 but Rook takes F7
loses to a beautiful counter tactic can
anybody find it black to play the fun
begins
why not Rook takes F7
so what you should notice here
is that the Knight on G3 restricts the
king the king does not have these two
Escape squares so in your mind you
should be generating a tactical pattern
where if this bishop lands on this
diagonal it's basically Checkmate the
move is Queen takes D5 and this actually
was a thing in the game as well de
Bishop C5 is not made
it's not made because white can drop the
Rook back to F2 but it's quite clear at
this point the blacks attack is
completely insurmountable black is gonna
get a ton of material for the queen you
can Stave off checkmate with h takes G3
and just moving the king away but black
picks up the Knight and now black has a
rook and two miners for the queen as
well as a raging attack it's winning for
black according to the engine
incredible idea
an incredible preparation nikito uh good
job learning the course
the move here is Knight takes C6 out of
nowhere and this is a different mating
pattern this one white mates Black's
King but the bishop pay six and and uh
Queen B7 hopefully you were able to see
this move Knight C6 ends the game but in
the other way
now notice that here Knight E2 check
doesn't do anything because black white
can just play Bishop Dixie too
and after Queen E8 the simplest is just
to recapture the Knight
simplest is to recapture the Knight
there are some more tactics here but
basically white wins
so I don't know if Lami considers Queen
B3 but I think Queen B3 might be the
most testing move now I think some
people would probably play Rook H to f8
here which is actually not a bad move
this is the engine's second suggestion
and here according to the engine white
should simply bring the Rook over to E1
and really solidify that E4 Pawn
and after Knight H5 Bishop drops back
the Knight dives into F4 the position is
complicated it's equal and playable for
both sides apparently the best thing to
do here is to tuck the king away to
relative safety on H1
black starts attacking with H5
and white starts attacking with a four
and we get just you know fascinating
Karo Khan fantasy play uh also
interesting is to play D5 here for white
D5 Open up The Bishop's diagonal and
attack on A7 of course black can play C5
and keep things closed but that gives
white another major asset in the form of
a protected passer albeit a blockaded
one
I'll be at a blockaded one but still
this would be a great position to
analyze according to the engine Bishop
to B5 here followed by Knight to C4 I
like White's position here I would play
this so I think for the next time we
face this queen B3 would be a very very
testing line Bishop takes F3 here is you
have to know that move because it's not
intuitive to me at all now we decided to
start with Queen A4
which uh in retrospect is probably wrong
and after King to B8 then we drop the
queen back to B3
and apparently here Bishop takes F3
again is the best move now let's compare
and contrast we had this exact position
with the King on C8 what difference does
the king being on B8 make well we go
down the exact same line bang bang bang
bang
ah wait a second aha
uh-huh Rook date Knight takes C4 Rook
takes F7 Knight D2
rookie seven Knight P3
Knight D2 rookie seven Knight B3
Bishop takes B3
and the key difference is that here in
contrast the King on B8 is simply a
safer piece white does not have this
additional check on E6 which is a great
asset if the king is on C8 so black is
attacking D4 black is slightly better
here because white is having a hard time
defending the D4 Pawn if white goes Rook
T1 blackened smoke The Rook out of E7
with rook hd8 and black is better white
is just saddled with these weaknesses
so apparently
the presence of the King on B8 versus C8
just benefits black in this exact
version of events but to me Knight H5 is
a very human move because this is the
main idea of Black's Queen side setup
and this loses
let's see and I oh and I missed Knight
takes C5
Knight takes C5 is winning
for some reason I didn't consider Knight
takes E5 this is tunnel vision this is a
great example of tunnel vision occurring
at you know the GM level because what
happened is I Associated this idea with
Bishop A6 right I kind of associated
with Bishop A6 and so I didn't take
other ideas seriously and I didn't
realize that after Knight takes C5 we're
threatening Knight takes C6 check so
conceptually I had the right thought but
I didn't consider this at all now what
about Knight takes C5 well here we play
Bishop take C5
Bishop takes C5 Rook takes F7 the game
is over black loses his Queen is the
queen can't move what black gets
checkmated so of course in this position
black has to play this miserable move
and go upon down but not only is it a
pawn down
white is also the attack rages on with
E5 and then Knight E4 and Rook ae1 it's
completely winning
unacceptable unacceptable Miss and I
just rushed it Bishop A6 well we took
over a minute but I had made up my mind
a lot earlier
so a good example of not
kind of limiting your thinking by
telling yourself I'm making this move in
order to make this other move right you
have to be more open-minded than that
and I think this is an instructive
example now Bishop takes E5 of course
you play Rook takes F7 immediately here
and you win the game
um not Bishop takes C5 check because if
Knight takes E5 and now you've lost your
opportunity to take on F7 because the
Knight defends the pawn so move order is
important here you have to choose the
right moment to take on F7 hopefully
that makes sense so Knight H5 should
have been a decisive mistake the correct
move for black here was Bishop takes F3
probably also King to A8 is a very
reasonable move this is a more
prophylactic approach that kind of keeps
the the spice of the game alive and this
would resemble the position that we were
analyzing just earlier uh with the King
still on C8
yeah no uh rookie mistake I played
Bishop A6 and now the tables turn
completely after Knight to B6 I'm pretty
sure the black is already let's see no
maybe not better
I'll check with the engine real quick
Bishop basics
Knight to B6 no white is still better
but I made another mistake
white is still better but I made another
mistake tunnel vision I was so enamored
with this idea of oh let's induce Knight
B6 and play 95 that I just didn't see
the forest for the trees and of course I
miss Bishop E6 which is the only move
that gives black an advantage the
correct move is indeed Bishop takes C5
and I misevaluated this as well white is
better here ba
oh my gosh but here okay here you have
to find a crazy computer move Bishop aha
Rook h8 is about equal which is what I
would assume but here white has a
ridiculous engine move that just okay it
makes some sense but not when there is a
hanging Rook let's see who can find this
move
you just have to attack like you just
have to attack the king now you might
say it's C4 well it's not C4 but it's
the right Square it's the wrong piece
the reason it's not C4 is because of
again Bishop E6 pinning the pawn and the
queen has no squares along the B file
such that you know or period so why does
a hard time getting C5
the correct move is actually Knight to
C4
and you might say well isn't Bishop E6
even stronger because it pins the bishop
well of course there are tactics as
usual there's Knight takes D6 after
Bishop takes B3 the Knight steps back
with the discovery black can give the
queen away for a piece but now the
Knight Dives in
and now white can win more material with
Knight C6 and Knight takes did obviously
with three pawns and a rook for the two
Miners and the Queens off the board
white is much better
and then you could follow up with the
prophylactic G3 to restrict the mobility
of Black's Knight
so
very very cool stuff here
now after Knight C4 black is in trouble
because Knight takes B6 Knight takes D6
all of it is a threat if you play Bishop
takes E5 well that loses to Knight takes
C5
it's about plus over minus apparently
black has to find this move
and here you trade everything on D6 and
again using the pawn as a hook in order
to open the f file and generate a very
nice post for the night
white is better white is a big
initiative here so in fact Bishop A6 was
not so bad if it was uh precipitated by
the right sequence of course I was just
blindly going for this line
and uh this came as a major major cold
shower
this game is a major major cold shower
but as I just checked it does not win
the game black is only slightly better
after we give away our piece only
slightly better believe it or not
so this is the attacking potential of
our pieces even after we give up a piece
we're still slightly better what was I
expecting here well of course I was
expecting this particular line although
now it occurs to me that black can still
play Queen takes C5
and this just leads to Wild
complications you cannot play d e
because after Bishop C5 Rook F2 again
there's Rook takes D2 similar to what we
looked at earlier
but there is the move Knight to C4
adding another attacker to the queen now
the queen is attacked from two different
sources
black can't take on C4 because of
checkmate
and the situation just becomes total
tactical pandemonium Rook takes B7 of
course is also a massive threat black
has to play this move
King F2 and apparently black has to find
Queen F4 check giving away the queen
black now has a rook and two miners for
the queen but white still has a pretty
strong attack on the queen side engine
gives a slight Edge for white
just insane
and the reason you have to play Queen F4
check is if you just move the queen
anywhere first of all the queen doesn't
have a lot of squares I guess this is
one of the only squares here there is
forced Checkmate let's see who can find
it white to play and mate the fastest
you have a beautiful move Queen takes B6
which does result in Checkmate but it's
not the fastest this is not the fastest
thank you yada yada man
what's the what's the move here this is
easy you should pause on YouTube and
figure this out good little mate
practice Yeah Rook takes A7 simply
removing the defender and then Queen B6
Queen B7 checkmate so
yeah so after King F2 the threat is Rook
takes B7 and Rook takes a seven that's
actually why you put the Knight on C4
also to attack the queen so you have to
forcibly remove the Rook from F7
alternatively you can also play Queen E7
same type of concept to force the Rook
off the board and get a bunch of
material for the queen so as crazy as
this line is you should understand the
sort of logic behind White's play why
not to start with Rook takes B7 and then
to play Knight C4
well the reason is that with the Rook no
longer on F7 after an id2 check and by
the way obviously you can't go King H1
because you get mated so you have to
take the plunge here black has Queen F4
check and The Rook isn't guarding that
square
and this gives black a Tempo the black
can use to draw the bishop back to C7
and guard the Knight thereby taking the
sting out of this particular mating
sequence
yeah Bishop C7 is another difficult move
but if you know the threat you have a
chance of finding it of course Knight C4
there's still Rook A7 and queen B7 maze
just incredible lines
so
yeah so all of this aside Bishop B6
circumvents all of these issues of
course if white plays Bishop back to C4
which I think a lot of people were
lobbying for the problem is Knight G3 HG
and Bishop E5 very very easy to forget
about this the Knight is x-rayed by The
Rook
because it's just not a tactical feature
that seems pertinent and yet it is
and as I was saying earlier if Queen C2
then the problem isn't the X-ray because
here the Knight on D2 is protected it's
the fact that well the bishop on A6 is
just hanging but why wasn't it hanging
earlier well it's because of Knight
takes C6 check
and why does black need to take on G3
first well because if black takes on E5
first White of course can recapture with
the bishop so everything should make
sense here it's just about putting the
puzzle pieces together you eliminate the
bishop you eliminate the Knight and then
the other Bishop can be captured
so for that reason we have to make a
graceful we have to hit the eject button
right that's what I would compare this
to you know that you're losing a piece
here what is the best way of generating
the maximum amount of material for that
piece this is an area where a lot of
players struggle when they encounter a
situation like this they completely
Panic right and just like give away a
piece or give away sometimes two pieces
so the point is you know that you're
losing the bishop in most lines
so instead of losing the bishop we
actually give up the Knight now we know
that the bishop is going to be left
intact and we gain a second pawn and we
generate long-term chances against
Black's King so we have to trade and we
drop the queen back to situ and we kind
of reset now I think Knight F4 is a
great move we start attacking with A4
and here I think our opponent missed a
major opportunity to solve the problems
on the queen side I think King A8 As
Natural as it is once before is played
we have now deprived black of the
opportunity to play C5 which is a move
that I had mentioned earlier I think
black should have played C5 here I think
black should have played C5 here and
after white plays D5
there is a hard to spot idea now I've
mentioned many times that when you are
up material one of the most common
technique involves sacrificing some of
that material back in order to change
the character of your advantage this is
a great example of that you play Knight
bd5
now you might say well wait a second
this is Checkmate it's not because black
can just dropped back to B6 and block
check after e takes D5 the point is not
that you take the bishop because then
white takes Black's Bishop it's the
simple Bishop takes D5
now what's going on here well the bishop
on A6 is hanging as is the G2 pawn and
if that pawn is captured all hell will
break loose on the king's side so for
example if white drops the bishop back
after Bishop takes G2 clearly the
situation for white is dire
and if white lifts The Rook up then
probably even Knight H3 check is is
winning the game because Knight takes F2
and the Knight on D2 eggs but it's not
the best according to the engine the
best according to the engine is Queen C6
setting up Knight H3 checkmate
so remember that and keep it in the back
of your head I think C5 would have given
black a nearly decisive Advantage
according to the computer where I can
keep the tension with Knight to F3 it's
about -1.5
black plays CD
uh and a CD
and if black plays G4 apparently Knight
E1 and white is somehow all right
because in this position the Knight on
F4 has lost the support of the pawn and
white has like A5 coming so this is
still very very sharp no question about
it but uh black is on the road it's
solving a lot of problems and I back to
D7 is a good move to force this bishop
off of A6
so hopefully this makes sense it's not
that after King Aid before black isn't
better I think black is still better but
the situation is starting to deteriorate
here so Bishop C8 we play A5
and of course the Tactical justification
which had to be very carefully
calculated is this line Rook A7 check
King B8 and now a very instructive
moment you might be attracted to this
tactical pattern and you might say ah
well after Queen A4 check white is
winning and white is winning
not with Checkmate on C7 but actually
with B7 and B8
queen or bishop and white makes the
second Queen and is winning
the problem though is that black is not
obliged to take the Rook remember this
because you just have to always keep it
in your mind that yeah your opponent can
decline your sacrifices so instead of
trying to go for the beauty prize the
simple Queen A4 ends the game
and in such situations it's always a
good idea to take a look at your own
King in order to tease out whether you
have the time to make a quiet move like
Queen to A4 and here the answer is yes
how do I know that well it's clear if
you look at White's King the black has
no way to whip up any meaningful attack
against our King you have to check this
move but you can just play King takes F1
and then you can play King take C2 and
clearly White's King escapes the checks
even King F2 is winning here and you can
sidestep Flex minor pieces and go to E1
and there is just no stopping Rook A8
and queen A7 and it's just made
whatever black does I mean Bishop B5 is
just checkmate now Fleck tries to run
away with King to C8 well then
you actually play King takes F1 to open
up the path for Queen A6 Queen V7 very
nice move by the way right you want to
go Queen A6 what's stopping you it's the
bishop get rid of the bishop
incredible the usage of White's King and
contributing to the attacking
to the attack so that was what I was
hoping for our opponent very alertly
drops the Knight back but once we get
the knight in once we get the knight in
and actually I also wanted to show what
happens after Queen to E6 which in
retrospect might have been Black's best
move
does anybody know what my idea was here
for white this is a little bit
speculative but in in practice this is
very hard to refute
and it's the similar thing that we did
in the game it's just a little bit more
involved in this case
it's what what tactical move
just blast open the file
Knight B6 yeah you sacrifice the Knight
in order in order to do wide in order to
open the a file we already know how
dangerous this is we're down two nights
but it doesn't matter
now we're threatening all sorts of
discoveries so Black's hand is
essentially forced but after Rook takes
A6 according to the engine what I missed
is that after King to B8 black is
surviving
and the position remains complicated
most humans I think would take on A6
and the chief difference is that now
there is this rookie a check move
here this is even cleaner
because you simply go around and
Checkmate the King on C7 remember the
differences here the queen is on E6
there it was on D6 now King B7 we bring
the Rook back to A7 what was the purpose
of White's last two moves well where did
The Rook come from it came from A6 and
it ends up on A7 why did we need to
remove it from A6 well we know what
peace wants to occupy the A6 Square it
is White's Queen so Queen A4 is winning
the game because again we're already
familiar with all the mating patterns
here Knight takes B6 Queen A6 there's no
stopping Checkmate you don't even need
the pawn anymore because you have too
many Avenues in too many mating patterns
Knight E2 check remember always just
sidestep don't pay attention to moves
like this as long as you make sure that
your king is safe you're fine
so this was my idea
our opponent understandably refrained
from it and after G3 already white is
better no question about it white is
already better
now I think Knight H3 and G4 is correct
because black saves the tempo but after
Rook takes F7 of course our opponent
makes the decisive mistake and allows
Knight B6 check what did Black have to
do in this position after which the
position remains very complicated it as
sad as it is to make a move like this
you have to drop the queen away because
you have to take the sting out of the
move Knight B6 check which by the way is
still a very serious idea
but here black has to play Knight B6 a b
and queen B6
in order to meet Rook A7 of course with
Queen A7 and then you get this type of
position which is probably a draw by
Perpetual check probably a draw by
Perpetual check so
I don't know Queen A2 check and queen F7
I mean white has Perpetual but not more
than that so here we probably would not
have gone Knight B6 we would have gone
maybe even a knight to D6
and black would probably move the rook
and we would play you know maybe B5
maybe a slower move like Rook a to F1
just doubling Rooks on the f file and
asserting our dominance now over the
king side clearly white no longer has a
material deficit right we have three
pawns for the minor piece which by
definition is enough
and not just any pawns we have a huge
Pawn Phalanx in the center so clearly
we've already overtaken the initiative
so in terms of where our opponent
actually went wrong I think the first
serious mistake was not to play C5 and
then the second was probably
um was probably Bishop C8 actually
because it yielded the C4 Square for our
Knight and that's what did Black in what
should black have done here maybe drop
the Knight back to D7 maybe start
attacking with H5 I would have played H5
I would have played H5 with black
because even though white gets A5 in
it's actually not such a big deal Knight
back to D7 we probably would have played
E5 and maybe gone 94 but clearly black
is still I think in the driver's seat
here in White's attack is not all that
clear
in this in this type of position maybe
C4
but apparently here Bishop B4 Queen E4
and 98 what a move defending C6 and the
bishop is trapped
and if white plays B5 Bang
I mean look at just the abundance of
tactics in these positions can't take
because of the fork Knight D7 to B8 is
the only move here actually that makes
this line work and it sets up the threat
of Rook takes D4
incredible
so of course
neither of us have seen even a hundredth
of that but Bishop C8 is just too
passive because it gives us too many
squares and obviously fast forwarding
Knight B6 check is really pretty but it
it works on simple tactics if a b then a
b winning the queen
or we could even play Rook takes f8
check first believe it or not if Knight
B6 then Rook takes Queen and again a lot
of newer players I think would be afraid
of this move remember that you can
always give your queen it's just like
any other piece don't treat the queen
like it's special it's just like any
other piece you can give it away for
other pieces you could cash it in and
gain a bunch of stuff in return
now after Queen B6 we played the
business-like move what was the
beautiful win well this is the theme
that you're already familiar with
now it's crucial here to avoid Queen A4
this is what I mentioned earlier you
always have to be aware of the safety of
your own King this actually gets
checkmated it's not just Perpetual check
it's Checkmate on G1
so instead you can play Rook to A8 check
and after King A8 this works very
cleanly all you need is the queen and
it's the similar pattern that we saw uh
earlier of course black can play King B7
now you play Rook takes h8 and this is
winning again Rook F2 just Queen takes
F2 black has no other way to encircle
the king if flagstro could land on G1
then it would be mate but blackstroke
has no way of making it even to the
first rank but I didn't even want to
bother with that given how many blunders
I made this game I just wanted to win
just by taking and playing a b
uh Knight B6 of course would have been a
little bit more resilient but uh we
would have played a queen A2 or the
Russian Schoolboy mode is just to play
Rook F1 and get rid of black stroke and
win the game
so we have a question uh by vanua wasn't
Queen B8 instead of Rook f8 more
resilient for black well Queen ba
doesn't work because of Rook takes D7
but you're right the correct move here
as we discussed would have been to play
Queen Z8 and get out of the PIN
black can also train King to B8 it so
that Knight B6 is not a check the
problem here is the Knight doesn't only
have B6 it can also drop a visit to E5
and I mean obviously here you could
probably just play Knight takes G4 I
mean as simple as that just
take a bunch of Pawns and this is
another piece of advice I have which is
that when you've sacrificed a minor
piece a lot of people assume that it's
either Checkmate or the sacrifice is a
failure remember that a minor piece is
just worth three points so sometimes the
best way to follow up a sacrifice like
this is just to win a bunch of funds
this is exactly what we did here I think
some players would get enamored with the
prospect of made and would start
considering this type of move right or
maybe Queen A4 but no you have to
realize that a piece is just three
points and the simplest is just to start
taking a bunch of puns of course it also
helps that this rook participates in the
attack but just because you've
sacrificed something big or blundered it
doesn't mean that you can't Garner the
equivalent number of puns later down the
line this isn't the sexiest but it's
going to get the job done but in terms
of the opening I'm going to do a little
bit of work in this line but our next
test when we face this is going to be
Queen to B3 because this basically
forces black to find Bishop takes F3 but
I I hope that you enjoyed the analysis
we finally got through a speedrun game
so it's a minor miracle and we got 3200
so this was a fantastic stream I'm super
pumped I'm gonna go to bed because
tomorrow is bullet brawl thank you
everybody have a great start to your
weekend and I'll see you guys later bye
foreign
[Music]